voilà donc pour l'audition de bruno
genevois le président de l'agencé
française de lutte contre le dopage je
vous propose maintenant de suivre une
deuxième audition celle de gérard
feldzer
ce consultant aéronautique est
auditionné dans le cadre d'une autre
commission denquête celle sur le coût
économique et financier de la pollution
de l'air alors que le salon du bourget
se tient en ce moment même
gérard feldzer exposé aux sénateurs
quelles solutions moins polluantes
pourrait s'appliquer au secteur aérien
il plaide par ailleurs devant les
sénateurs pour le principe du pollueur
payeur
notre dernière édition de la journée
celle de monsieur gérard feldzer
consultants en aéronautique etc aussi
régional d'île de france
je rappelle que cette audition est
ouverte au public et à la presse ce
qu'elle fut l'objet d'une captation
audiovisuelle qui sera diffusé sur le
site du sénat
je vais maintenant conformément à la
procédure applicable commission denquête
demander à la personne à la personne
auditionnée de bien vouloir prêter
serment en rappelant pour la forme qu un
faux témoignage devant une autre
commission est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 434 13 14 et 15 du
code pénal monsieur gérard feldzer prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levé la main droite et lille
je le jure je le jure merci à la suite
de votre exposé introductif ma collègue
rapporteur de la commission denquête
leila aichi vous posera un sens de
questions puis nous ouvrirons le débat
et nous avons jusqu'à 19h30
voilà vous avez la parole si vous voulez
bien j'appuie sur le bouton là
et il s'agit en fait d'énergie embarquée
c'est pour ça que je passe pour un
spécialiste aéronautique mais je suis
plutôt spécialisés transport des
systèmes et d énergie embarquée
l'aviation si on se limite à l'aviation
s'est pas seulement ça c'est applicable
dans toute la filière énergétique
d'une façon générale je regrette
beaucoup que concernant les énergies
embarquer la france n'ait pas été
suffisamment présente notamment dans
l'hydrogène et la filière hydrogène
comme nos amis allemands par exemple
alors c'est surtout valable pour les
voitures mais pour les avions on
commence à voir des projets notamment
chez altran concernant des des systèmes
dont les soutes pour l'énergie notamment
l'énergie au sol mais ça devrait pouvoir
se généraliser par la suite
par ailleurs les batteries des avions
alors je ne sais pas si j'ai su hors
sujet ou pas dit lymphome 1 les
batteries nique au nickel cadmium sont
moyennement performante
on a fait des progrès dans les batteries
il fallait pour l'équivalent d'un litre
d'essence de kérosène transporté en
équivalent énergétique à peu près 55 kg
de batteries au plomb
on est aujourd'hui avec les batteries
lithium ion lithium polymère lithium fer
à environ 30 kilos mais on fait des
progrès tous les jours le 2e progrès le
deuxième la deuxième problématique de
ses batteries
c'est leur conditionnement d'une part
parce qu'elle prenne feu elles prennent
feu spontanément c'est une des
hypothèses dans la disparition du
malaisien sur lequel j'ai beaucoup
enquêté un avion qu'on n'a jamais
retrouvé et également des constatations
de feu de batterie sur plusieurs
compagnies aériennes une technologique
est assez fine c'est de la chimie très
haut de gamme et ensuite eh bien il ya
le démantèlement des batteries le
recyclage de ces batteries qui est assez
compliquée assez cher aujourd'hui
je vous donne un exemple j'ai été
interrogé le directeur des véhicules
électriques chez renault je vais
demander qu'est ce que vous faites de
vos batteries au bout de cinq ans
lorsqu'elles vont perdu 20 % de leurs
capacités il m'a dit pour l'instant rien
puisqu'en s'engager vis-à-vis nos
clients de remettre des batteries neuves
pour retrouver leur autonomie
il me semble que il faut travailler
cette filière
c'est ce que je fais à mon tout petit
niveau j'équipe des véhicules
utilitaires avec les 80% restants des
batteries de ces voitures soit 10
envisagées et il doit y avoir une
économie circulaire en tous les cas un
troisième une troisième voie il est
insensé aujourd'hui de mettre au pilon
des patries qui ont 4 5 en sachant
qu'elle va encore 75 80 % de leur
capacité notamment on peut les utiliser
pour du stockage d'énergie stockage
d'énergie pourquoi d'abord pour les pays
africains qui n'ont pas d'accès à
l'énergie avec des containers de
récupération c'est aussi c'est
l'économie circulaire pour faire accéder
à l'énergie dans un container qui peut
contenir j'ai un prototype que je
pourrais vous montrer un jour une
station satellitaire pour la télé les
télécommunications un frigo une machine
à coudre et surtout une pompe pour
amener l'eau potable
bref devenir le centre du village en
aviation
on a le roulage des avions lorsque
j'étais commandant de bord air france
j'ai photographié un monde totalisateur
de carburant au roulage chaque décollage
chaque roulage pour année au décollage
vous fait dépenser entre 200 et 1000
litres de carburant et je disais à jean
paul béchat qui était le patron de
safran à l'époque je dis mais moi des
moteurs électriques sur mes roues qui
dit moteur électrique fou de la
puissance électrique
donc soit par batterie soit par la paix
eu
la paix us et le petit moteur qui est
dans la queue qui tourne extrêmement
vite pour donner l'air de l'énergie re1
l'avion ils ont fini par le faire
ça s'appelle le green taxis des moteurs
électriques sous les roues de l'avion
il faut savoir que le roulage des avions
à roissy ces 300 mille tonnes de co2
c'est l'équivalent du périphérique
donc si on arrive déjà à résoudre ce
petit problème c'est déjà pas mal sauf
que ça s'applique uniquement aux moyens
courriers pourquoi parce que sur des
airbus 380 3,40 sur lequel j'étais ou
des boeing triple sept le fait d'emmener
200 kg sur un long courriers
supplémentaires vous fait dépenser en
dix heures de vol à peu près la moitié
de la masse et ailleurs 100 kg en
pétrole
donc c'est pas rentable du point de vue
économique et du point de vue écologique
alors c'est là où les chemins se
croisent entre l'aviation et les autres
moyens de transport c'est qu'il faut
imaginer les tracteurs détracteurs qui
emmène jusqu'au bout jusqu'à
l'atterrissage jusqu'à la piste de
décollage et après l'atterrissage
jusqu'au parking et depuis le parking et
là on ferait un progrès immense
du point de vue de la pollution du point
de vue du bruit pour les riverains et en
général pour l'aviation ça fait
réfléchir sauf que ça se heurte un
problème politique pour le coup il faut
taxer les avions n'ont pas la masse
comme ça fait aujourd'hui mais avec un
facteur de pollution
c'est à dire que un avion qui utilisent
le
soit le green taxis soit le tractage
électrique automatique
il sera moins taxés que les autres c'est
une prime pour moi à l'aviation dites
propres à l'est jamais vraiment propre
mais elle peut l'être un petit tout
petit peu plus ses véhicules sortent du
champ de compétence de nos avionneurs je
réunis à peu près 20 25 directeurs de
recherche tout transport confondus
airbus valeo michelin etc et on essaye
de entrevoir l'aviation du futur en 2050
ça fait partie des préoccupations et la
mise en relation de valeo par exemple
qui s'est très très bien faire les
véhicules automatiques ce qu'on appelle
aussi la voiture connectée avec les
routes de cinquième génération et bien
les savoir-faire peuvent se croiser
c'est ce qui se fait et moi j'en suis
extrêmement satisfait les frontières se
brise entre les industriels de la route
du fer alstom qui a beaucoup de
compétences sur les énergies également
pour le bien des transports en général
c'est pour ça que je dis aviation
batterie très bien mais c'est à la même
problématique il doit y avoir une
filière énergie me semble-t-il tout
transport confondus pour aller de la
conception de la recherche jusqu'au
démantèlement
merci cher
comme nous y étions engagés je donne la
parole lamerat porter merci de votre
exposé le sujet précis de notre
commission denquête et le coût
économique et financier de la pollution
de l'air nous entamons en fait la phase
d des solutions puisque nous avons
abordé dans un premier temps l'aspect
sanitaire et dans un deuxième temps
l'aberration si je puis dire économique
et financière et aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans la phase ii des solutions ma
question va être assez simple en même
temps somme toute est ce que vous pensez
que d'une manière générale les
perspectives d'emploi et de
développement industriel en lien avec
une amélioration de la qualité de l'air
et du développement durable pourrait
être des marchés porteurs si oui quelles
sont selon vous les axes où les les les
personnes morales ou les personnes
plutôt les personnes morales ou les
administrations qui sont sensibles à
cette écoute ou qu'elles sont
éventuellement puisque vous êtes aussi
conseiller régional les les résistances
justement à ce changement industriels ou
en tout cas cette résistance a impulsé
une autre dynamique puisque on arrive à
un certain nombre d'auditions et c'est
vrai qu'on sent qu'il ya beaucoup de
fiera peut-être pas jusqu'à la des
résistances mais beaucoup d'inquiétude
pour assurer justement cette cette
transition je vous remercie
alors en ce qui concerne l'aviation il
ya deux phénomènes irait pollution de
l'air et le bruit et c'est une
contradiction qui font assumer depuis
des années parce que lorsqu'on veut de
la puissance donc décoller le plus vite
possible et faire le moins de bruit
possible aux environs de l'aéroport ont
fait du bruit
si on veut pas de bruit et bien on aura
la verse donc il ya un compromis à faire
qui est pas évident ce qui est évident
c'est que la pression des riverains sera
de plus en plus forte
ça devient insupportable je peux le
comprendre et donc il va falloir trouver
radicalement des solutions lesquels
peuvent l être
je parle de bruit puis je ferai après la
pollution de l'air
pour le bruit ce sont des évidemment des
trajectoires qui sont radicalement
différentes
c'est à dire accepter que dans des
heurts notamment la nuit mais il va robe
de plus en plus d'aéroports qui vont
faire fermer l'aéroport de nuit comme à
francfort par exemple eh bien ce qui
n'est pas évident parce qu'il ya des
choix à faire
si vous fermez la nuit vous l'avez vous
mettez en danger une compagnie comme
fedex à roissy et c'est quand même deux
mille emplois derrière
donc voilà il faut en tenir compte sur
ceux de nuit on peut très bien imaginer
de demander la dg assez de changer
radicalement les trajectoires sur clay
autour de l'aéroport par exemple en
montée ça fait perdre deux trois minutes
de vol mais si c'est le prix à payer il
faut le faire et puis ensuite augmenter
les pentes durant la proche les pentes
de descente
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
pente standard pour pratiquement tous
les aéroports du monde qui sont de 3
degrés vous allez vous mettez sur un
plan de 3 degrés vous mettez la moitié
de la puissance à peu près ça il faut la
pousser probablement à 5 degrés je dis
pas que c'est miraculeux
parce qu'il ya le bruit aérodynamique
qui fait quand même largement autant de
bruit que le moteur maintenant et mais
en tous les cas cela concernerait
beaucoup moins de monde autour des
aéroports
aujourd'hui lohan s estiment que les
personnes concernées autour des
aéroports c'est à peu près de 150
millions de personnes
bon il faut relativiser parce que le
bruit est limitée autour des aéroports
même s'il ya beaucoup de population
alors que le tgv est bien et du point de
vue du bruit et bien il intéresse toutes
les personnes tout le long de la
trajectoire
donc il faudrait faire le calcul entre
ces différents moyens de transport et
les pollutions sonores
il ya un organisme en france qui est
formidable il s'appelle l'onera que vous
connaissez qui fait de la recherche sur
le bruit ils ont une chambre un écho ide
à saclay et qui est à orsay pardon et
qui est extrêmement performante
ça fait partie d'un programme européen
les allemands ont de leur côté dlr qui
est l'équivalent de l'onera les
recherches doivent être non pas franco
françaises et européennes à ce niveau là
on a fait d'énormes progrès en trente
ans on a divisé par deux le bruit et les
émissions sur les réacteurs et les
performances aérodynamiques ont beaucoup
progressé également sauf que on s'est
fait rattraper par la croissance du
transport aérien je vous rappelle qu'à 3
milliards de personnes transportées
et on aura 7 milliards en 2030 et qu' il
ya un avion par seconde qui décolle
aujourd'hui on aura deux et que on aura
beau faire des progrès c'est
asymptotique on n'arrivera jamais à
rattraper la croissance du transport
aérien donc il faut un changement de
paradigme
il faut une rupture technologique la
rupture technologique
en gros c'est le conte c'est ce qu'avait
fait le concorde pour la vitesse
il faut la même rupture technologique
pour les émissions et pour le bruit
alors quel sera l'avion du futur de ce
point de vue là probablement des aides
et des moteurs intégrés dans les ailes
pour préserver du bruit lorsque le bruit
est en dessous les moins diffusés et
également souffler les ailes du point de
vue aérodynamique set extrêmement
rentable ça permet d'avoir moins de
pousser notamment pour le décollage est
ce que j'ai à peu près répondu avec à
sion
vous pensez que c'est des marchés
potentiels pour notre pays absolument
c'est une chance c'est une opportunité
parce que il faut pas oublier une chose
on est dans un marché extrêmement
concurrentiel
on est dans un marché où on ne paie pas
la même chose
suivant l'endroit où l'on se trouve le
drame des compagnies aériennes
européennes notamment air france et la
concurrence du golfe notamment emirates
à ce qu'ils payent le pétrole beaucoup
moins cher que la pollution ça les
concerne pas que ils payent les avions
moins cher qui a pas de charges sociales
etc
vous connaissez le problème mieux que
moi donc aujourd'hui on peut rattraper
ce genre de handicap par des avions ou
du moins aidé à la conception des avions
parce que le client c'est d'abord la
compagnie aérienne et ensuite ce sont
les clients qui choisissent
si vous choisissez d'être une compagnie
vertueuse
je suis persuadé que le client choisira
la compagnie la plus vertueuse il ça
doit s'accompagner par là c'est ma
casquette de conseiller régional par des
taxes différencier entre c'est qu'ils
sont vertueux et ceux qui le sont moins
je vous donne un exemple fedex faisait
poser il n'ya pas encore très longtemps
des airbus a300 des 727 on les a
tellement accès pour qu'ils achètent des
triples 7 que maintenant c'est un triple
c est un avion beaucoup moins bruyant
beaucoup plus moderne on peut créer des
emplois sur l'avion silencieux l'avion
moins lourds moins cher dans la filière
excellence qui est safran avec les
accords qui sont tout à fait formidable
entre general electric et snecma rolls
royce
également il d'ailleurs les hackers côté
acteurs croisette ce point de vue là
pour des moteurs beaucoup plus propre
d'une part et que la recherche soit
ciblée alors la difficulté c'est que
pour sortir un avion ou sortir un
nouveau moteur il faut aller
10 15 ans aujourd'hui on vend des 350
qui n'est pas encore sorti en compagnie
aérienne on vend des 3,80 il sera encore
là en 2050
donc on n'aura pas un progrès
considérable mais il faut se préparer
pour qu'en 2030 on est déjà des nouveaux
avions avec des créations d'emplois dans
la filière ingénieur bien sûr mais aussi
dans la filière entretien qui va changer
parce qu'on sera beaucoup on électrique
notamment avec des circuits électriques
qui vont remplacer les circuits
hydrauliques pneumatiques ce sont des
nouveaux métiers et franchement c'est
une opportunité on voit le succès
d'airbus
faut pas lâcher herbeux et ça a été un
succès pourquoi parce qu'il assortit
l'a320 qui est le premier airbus glass
cockpit c'est à dire des écrans et à
commandes de vol électriques un avion
intelligent qui protège dans les
domaines de vol il a 25 ans il avait
énormément d'avancé bien avancé
aujourd'hui il faut la prendre
du point de vue de l'environnement bon
vous avez beaucoup évoqué la question
d'ailleurs plutôt des nuisances sonores
concernant la pollution atmosphérique on
a auditionné assemble d'acteurs du monde
de l'aéronautique et on a eu le
sentiment tous les cas
c'est ce qu'on a ressenti concernant la
dir est la pollution du monde
aéronautique et des avions sur les
aéroports que le dispositif qui alors il
ya deux choses il ya notamment tout le
travail qui est fait par les
constructeurs et il semble que c'est
problématique soit assez bien prise en
compte notamment au travers du gifas est
ce que vous partagez ce point de vue
alors je vais pas trahir mes camarades
de l'aviation le programme que clean sky
ou d'autres programmes européens ont
fait des efforts mais pas suffisant mais
semble-t-il c'est pas parce qu'on va
dire que l'on fait que deux et demi pour
cent c'est ce qui va nous font tous les
cas de la responsabilité du co2 qu on
doit forcément
se priver d autres émissions qui font
tout autant d'émoi dommageable les
oxydes et les particules qui sont
extrêmement nuisible aux alentours des
aéroports
on en parle beaucoup en ville mais
l'aviation y contribue pour beaucoup et
de là on a encore d'énormes d'énormes
progrès à faire mais chacun défend son
bifteck c'est à dire le dur j'étais à
l'aviation marchande pouvait pas la
vision marchande pardon le maritime et
bien je vice-président de ports de paris
donc que je me soucie des péniches et du
trafic fluvial qui se targue de avec une
barge de éviter 400 camions sur le
périphérique
sauf que c'est comme la marine marchande
qui transportent 90% du volume de
marchandises dans le monde
elle aimait 4,6 pour cent de co2 mais
pas que et si on ne fait rien demain
très vite elle aura dépassé toutes les
autres émissions sur terre et pourtant à
la tonne kilomètre transportée
c'est effectivement les meilleurs
l'aviation c'est un peu pareil c'est pas
parce qu'on dit qu'on n'est n'est que
deux et demi pour cent que c'est une
situation d'avenir pas du tout parce que
2011 sera encore une fois c'est que pour
le co2 et puis d'autre part on va se
faire attraper par les autres moyens de
transport
c'est à dire que il est quand même plus
facile en investissement et en sécurité
de faire une voiture propre que de faire
un avion propre un avion
avant qu'il soit propre si on me met par
exemple du bio carburant de troisième
génération dans un premier temps même ça
ça prend du temps et bien le 2b pourtant
il va rapidement si vous mettez vous
interrogez monsieur jean marc jancovici
je ne sais pas s'il est venu ici eh bien
on atteindra facilement les 10 à 15 %
mais sur la sur la question j'y reviens
puisque c'est aussi faim c'est d'abord
notre sujet le coût économique et
financier de la pollution de l'air ce
que nous on dit donc les personnes
auditionnées et du monde de l'ère
nautique
on avait quand même le sentiment 1 que
les mesures sont bien faites sur les
aéroports des polluants et pas quand
vous dites un pas seulement du co2 mais
bon donc le vous avez là l'air de nous
dire que
c'est pas tout à fait ça à dire que moi
j'entends ce que vous dites sur les
efforts qui sont faits par rapport
notamment au co2 mais on a ce qui nous
importe nos si la pollution je dirais
aux micro particules ou aux particules
ultrafines et puis le s'agissant des
aéroports on voit bien également que les
quenouilles enfin l'acceptation sociale
aujourd'hui elle et il est plutôt
dépassée je prenais l'exemple deux
exemples c'est bon l'air au port de
nantes on voit le je dirais le à front
du refus
enfin même si n'est qu' il est peut-être
minoritaire mais enfin bon il fait
suffisamment parlé pour considérer qu'on
peut pas le balayer d'un revers de main
et de la même manière à l'autre bout de
la france quand vous avez des capitaux
des prises de capitaux étrangers dans un
aéroport on se pose d'autres questions
donc on voit qu'il devient difficile de
gérer
finalement la question sociale la
question économique et puis pratiquement
la question des capitaux qui s'ajoute
donc à la cas la question
environnementale
vous avez dit tout à l'heure j'ai
entendu qu'ils avaient des solutions que
vous étiez plutôt optimiste donc que
faut-il penser par rapport à ce que je
viens de vous demandez vous êtes mieux
placé que moi vous fait ça toute la
journée tous les jours toute l'année de
faire des compromis entre le bien-être
l'économie les emplois créer de la
richesse
je suis président du comité régional de
tourisme
j'ai fait un bilan carbone du tourisme à
paris bon voila il est ce qu'il est et
donc il faut vivre avec et essayer de
faire mieux
moi j'étais convaincue qu' il faut des
programmes européens la france tout seul
ne pourra rien faire des programmes
européens beaucoup plus ambitieux qu est
ce qui est proposé aujourd'hui
la filière hydrogène avec un facteur de
de combustion qui est bien supérieur à
celui du kérosène d'une part mais
l'avion est complètement différent parce
que probablement une aile volante si on
prend de l'hydrogène gazeux allait bien
il faut pouvoir le mettre quelque part
donc c'est un avion totalement différent
mais il faut envisager assez rapidement
ce changement de paradigme avec
peut-être aussi des valeurs variable
voilure variable ça veut dire je patron
très technique mais on a des volets au
décollage mais c'est plus que ça ce sont
des ailes pivotante et c'est donc il ya
des solutions qui paraissent aujourd'hui
très lointaine mais l'avion électrique
on pense être en mesure de sortir un
avion moyen-courrier 200 places avec
deux heures d'autonomie c'est pas moi
qui le dit mais ces rebus avec le
programme voltaire avec des matériaux
supraconducteurs pour que les moteurs
électriques ne chauffe pas trop etc
m'enfin on a des solutions aujourd'hui
le seul problème c'est qu'il faut
trouver l'équilibré entre
l'investissement qui est extrêmement
lourd et l'amortissement derrière ils
ont ces compagnies ont des contraintes
des contraintes financières
on n'ose pas de marée à nouveau
programme
regardez ce qu'a coûté le programme a380
qui a doublé voire presque triplé en
quelques années donc se lancer dans un
avion radicalement nouveau comme le
concorde par exemple concorde a pris 11
ans d'études et développement avant d'y
arriver si on faisait le même et ses
efforts qu'on l'avait fait à l'époque
pour le concorde on y arriverait on y
arriverait beaucoup plus vite
c'est une question d' aide aussi j'aime
pardon excusez moi nous attend vous
n'avez pas et d'airbus et de concorde
eux je dirais que malheureusement a
posteriori je préfère qu'on parle
d'airbus club concorde jeu concorde il a
coûté cher me semble-t-il il a eu du mal
à percer parce qu'il veut mais
l'existence partout et finalement non
mais j'ai fait complètement d'accord
avec vous je suis complètement d'accord
avec vous je suis pas en train de
défendre le concorde
je défends vous prenez l'exemple de la
rupture
la rupture technologique c'est à dire
que le concorde faisait partie de
l'aérospatiale à l'époque donc d'airbus
aujourd'hui je parlais pas de l'avion
concorde et à rebuts et ça fait partie
de la même compagnie aujourd'hui qui
s'appelle airbus
aujourd'hui on mettrait les mêmes zones
derrière ces mêmes ingénieurs qui ont
été brillants même si le concorde suis
complètement d'accord avec vous c'est
une aberration on veut dire un truc qui
fait j'en ai fait du concours douala qui
fait 10 tonnes à l'heure le chercheur
c'est complètement dingue courage et on
en est à 20 litres au cent par passager
ça va quoi d'accord mais il n'empêche
que ils ont été absolument géniaux c'est
un appareil qui avait tout inventé
l'airbus n'existerait pas s'il n'y avait
pas eu le concorde les circuits
électriques les transferts de carburant
pour le centrage il y avait tout sur cet
avion les commandes de vol électriques
c'était le concorde est bon dans les
années 60
donc ils ont su trouver aujourd'hui ce
qui a fait la qualité d'airbus
on n'a pas changé les systèmes
hydrauliques sont les mêmes il ya du
verre il ya du jaune il ya du rouge
c'est pareil ils ont ils ont
révolutionné
l'aviation civile du point de vue
technologique il faut faire ce même
effort pour l'avion propres c'est une
nécessité
on n'a pas le choix de toute façon dont
vous pardon vous pensez que l'avion
propre il
il sera on va dire et électrique je
cherche pas à savoir 1 d'où vient oui
d'accord oui
dans un premier temps où quelque peu
style être à hydrogène avec des moteurs
et des nouvelles velis qui seront à
l'arrière de l'avion
finalement les gros réacteurs
aujourd'hui c'est son des moteurs à
hélices 1 80% de la puissance passe par
l'hélice dans le compresseur alors on
passera peut-être par ces phases là mais
l'électricité route puissance à haut
rendement elle est presque déjà là donc
oui on y arrivera quand j'ai présenté à
airbus et un petit programme d'avions
école il ya trois quatre ans j'étais
directeur du musée de l'air l'époque
j'ai dit ça serait bien qu'on fasse
et c'est patrick gandil de l'aviation
civile qui m'a dit écoute je suis
emmerdé avec les vous traduisez pas mon
amour avec les riverains pardon avec les
riverains tous ces nobles mais on est
filmé aïe aïe aïe alors il fallait faire
quelque chose pour les riverains et il
faut faire quelque chose pour les
riverains
on vit dans une société où on doit
partager les territoires et on a droit
de dormir et on a le droit de aussi de
prendre son pique nique
le dimanche donc j'ai proposé à ce qu'on
fasse un avion électrique école un truc
de fou mais ça a été fait et finalement
et arbustes a pris très au sérieux c'est
arrivé aujourd'hui ça s'appelle lifan
c'est un petit avion électrique biplace
cuts un peu compliqué c'est vrai mais
qui donne à voir le fait qu'un gros
industriels comme ça accepte de faire un
tout petit avion pour les aéro club
ça prouve que l'avion est considéré
comme un banc d'essai on essaie les
énergies embarqué on essaie les nouveaux
moteurs on sait les refroidir on
travaille sur les bms les batteries
management system etc
et je trouve ça très bien et puis il ya
d'autres initiatives
il ya en ce moment le solar impulse
bertrand piccard qui fait le tour du
monde
il a de trouver des partenaires privés
des montres etc et les industriels ont
apporté leur savoir faire
je trouve que c'est un mariage
formidable parce que c'est un événement
médiatique d'abord ça donne envie
il fait le tour du monde sans une seule
goutte de pétrole c'est quand même un
signe
alors évidemment il est tout seul et on
fera pas un avion de transport solaire
ok mais ont fait d'énormes progrès il a
mis dans son avion le solar impulse ce
qu'il y avait de mieux en batterie ce
qui avait de mieux en bms qui avait
c'est de mieux en moteurs électriques et
et en panneaux solaires et aujourd'hui
ça montre la voie les chinois viennent
aujourd'hui avec des petits avions
écoles qu'ils ont fait homologuer parce
qu'ils ont racheté des compagnies
américaines et
flo veine qui sont très forts dans ce
domaine bon voilà ça va commencer par
les petits avions et puis petit à petit
on va grossir on va apprendre en
marchant et je trouve ça très bien moi
je fais extrêmement confiants dans
l'avion de l'avenir l'avion propre camp
jeudi l'avion propre c'est pas tout à
fait ça parce que c'est jamais propre
rien les propres mais en tous les cas
beaucoup plus vertueux sur ces sujets
justement pour la vie un avenir qu'elle
est les plus grandes qu'elles selon vous
les plus grande résistance au changement
est ce que ça viendrait plutôt des
industriels est ce que éventuellement la
classe politique ou une ambiance
générale de notre pays qui fait que ça
peut être compliqué ou au contraire vous
sentez que justement qu'il peut y avoir
une dynamique en ce sens alors il ya des
il ya des résistances financière
évidemment canton industriel vous lui
dites je vais même faire un avion
complètement nouveau avec une rupture
technologique et un coup derrière donc
il faut trouver l'argent alors l'argent
il faut aussi le canaliser parce que il
ya des programmes européens qui ont été
attribués à de la recherche quelquefois
qui n'avait pas cet objectif
on a pensé par exemple à faire le
personnel plein
ça c'est le nayrac aïssa c'est un avion
taxi automatique
bon on s'est posé la question de savoir
si on pouvait se passer des pilotes
pourquoi pas un taxi en pleine ville
mais il faut que ce soit des avions
électriques pour le coup donc on étudie
ce genre de choses mais une aide massive
à la recherche d'abord créateur
créateurs d'emplois et puis garder aussi
nos savoir faire c'est quand même
important on a des savoir-faire aux
états unis il faut aller voir comment
marchent les mighty il en sortit alors
c'est pour l'anecdote
j'étais d'avoir et j'ai même essayé ils
ont une voiture avion et james bond très
drôle mais des étudiants qui ont monté
leur boîte quand certifier leurs avions
et ça s'appelle le terra foule ya
peut-être vous pourrez le voir sur
internet votre voiture se transforme en
avion et là ils en font
un des systèmes extrêmement léger avec
des matériaux alors du carbone
évidemment mais l'avion du futur il est
au banc d'essai est là et c'est
formidable ce qui se passe donc d aide
aux industriels pour les aider à aller
de l'avant avec un mariage des
universités qui me semble-t-il
contrairement à ce qui se passe ailleurs
n'est pas suffisamment ancrées je vous
prends l'exemple de le pfl l'école
polytechnique de lausanne pierre
lapointe de pratiquement tous les moyens
de transport que ce soit le planet solar
le bateau qui a fait le tour du monde
en solaire le solar impulse et ses
excuses on mate vous interrompre vous
êtes en train de dire que vous pensez
que les industries ne fonctionne pas
suffisamment fait travaillent pas
suffisamment avec les universités
absolument je pense qu'il doit y avoir
des rapprochements beaucoup plus
important que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui il y en a on confie des
études et pas seulement dans l'aviation
mais me semble t'il pas suffisamment et
puis un vrai programme européen qui
existe mais qu'il faut renforcer
on va être pris en tenaille par la
recherche américaine la recherche
asiatiques qui jusqu à maintenant copier
mais se contente en plus copié ses
nouveaux galons les copier bientôt et la
russie qui avec les asiatiques peuvent
faire un troisième pôle et qui me paraît
important il faut garder de la vence est
gardée de l'avant ça veut dire investir
dans la recherche et investir et
l'investir excusez moi nous attend si
vous pouviez préciser votre pensée
puisqu'on faudra voir le rapport le plus
le plus précieux quand vous dites pris
en tenaille par les états unis et
certains pays asiatiques est ce que vous
pouvez illustrer vos propos et bien là
oui on essaie d'aller il ya trois phases
moi il ya une entreprise que j'aime
beaucoup c'est michelin parce que on
réunit
les directeurs de recherche
régulièrement tous les mois
et puis on dit allez-y montrer vos
projets et on vous montrez vos projets à
long terme
à long terme c'est l'échelle de 30 ans
et puis on recule en arrière pour aller
voir les projets à moyen terme et à
court terme court terme c'est le
quotidien
je trouve ça très bien parce que ça
permet de se projeter dans l'avenir il y
en a d'autres qui font ça d'ailleurs
très bien sûr les petites initiatives
quotidiennes c'est la sncf on s'y attend
pas mais ça fonctionne vraiment bien de
ce côté là c'est le système participatif
des personnels mais pour certaines
compagnies je pense aux états unis y en
a beaucoup
la nasa est très intégrée avec le monde
universitaire l'onera en france aussi
mais il faut que me semble-t-il et des
programmes beaucoup plus ambitieux que
ça il ya un programme sur lequel on a
été très en avance sur la recherche et
la pile à combustible notamment au cea à
grenoble
et c'est un autre exemple ça concerne
pas que l'aviation mais la filière
hydrogène en france encore une fois elle
a été délaissé les allemands ont ainsi
investi énormément
les japonais également vous avez là la
toyota à pile à combustible qui va
sortir cette année à la
commercialisation
ils vont résoudre du coup le problème du
recyclage des batteries et il me semble
que là on a raté une marche
c'est un petit peu dommage mais si vous
prenez l'aviation c'est pareil si vous
prenez le train
alstom c'est pareil vous avez une
concurrence chinoise qui est terrible et
la faune investir là aussi dans des
technologies et ses technologies elles
se croisent
si vous prenez l'énergie dans le tgv
vous l'avez également dans l'aviation
donc oui faut prendre faut se méfier
parce que le devenir industriel de la
france il passe par la recherche et le
développement
alors l'aviation il consacre beaucoup de
choses mais il faut qu'elles fois
peut-être beaucoup plus intégrée avec
les autres moyens de transport et avec
toutes les grandes écoles et les
universités rapport pour revenir dans
les quelques minutes qui nous restent au
coût économique et financier de la
pollution de l'air et dans le domaine
qui nous concerne en ce moment
finalement quelles solutions vous voyez
pas ce que vous l'aborder dans le gérer
la problématique dans son aspect général
mais il faut bien pour faire la mutation
vous avez donné tout à l'heure les
progressions qui était proposé je dirais
parler par l'industrie de l'aéronautique
vous dites ce que je te casse qu'on peut
entendre
il faudra aller plus vite et en même
temps comment il allait plus vite
répondre à la tente du marché satisfaire
à les global mans la société et ces
individus
avec leurs demandes contradictoires mais
en répondant à l'objectif qu'on se fixe
nous au travers de cette commission
denquête c'est essayer justement de
mieux évaluer le coût de la qualité de
l'air est donc finalement de mieux
traiter le problème de la pollution tout
en restant attractifs dans les modes de
déplacement donc donc de l'aérien
finalement quel et je dirais pour vous
la voix qu'on doit emprunter
moi à mon avis c'est la même formule que
en emploi depuis longtemps mais qu'on
n'applique pas ces pollueurs payeurs
c'est à dire que quand la russie la
chine les etats unis se sont opposées la
dernière conférence climat à la taxe
carbone pour les avions moi j'ai
beaucoup d'espoir sur la coque 21 à la
fin de l'année pour que l'on puisse
contribuer avec l'argent le prix du
carbone à la recherche pour faire en
sorte que ce soit le moins polluant
possible et le moins brouillon possible
je pense que c'est vraiment une question
d'argent c'est pas la technologie on la
connaît à peu près c'est une question de
l'argent mais si je regarde le sommet
européen qui a coûté un petit peu
d'argent
là ce week-end je m'aperçois que parce
qu'à d'autres événements et tant pis
mais de mon point de vue je ne considère
pas que c'est des événements que le cap
pour tous majeurs je me suis aperçu que
finalement la question du climat qui
devait être le seul
la seule question à l'ordre du jour elle
a été reléguée à ce qu'il restait de
temps le dernier jour donc je me dis
il faut - formulé un souhait c qui ait
pas d'événements importants ou
dramatiques en fin d'année faute de quoi
j'ai l'impression que le climat
resterait une question peut-être encore
secondaire je suis optimiste pessimiste
vous êtes réaliste c'est vrai que bon je
serai pas rentrer dans le giron de
nicolas hulot
si je pensais pas comme ça c'est à dire
que et être élus europe ecologie les
verts parce que on il faut arrêter de
faire des victimes pour lesquelles la
technologie n'a pas apporté grand chose
je veux dire ceux qui respirent autour
des aéroports c'est pas ceux qui
prennent l'avion
donc il ya une question de il ya une
question de moralité aussi quand on dit
pollueur payeur ça veut dire faire en
sorte que les gens qui amènent bon de la
richesse on fait travailler
cent mille personnes dans les aéroports
il faut en tenir compte mais en même
temps je pense que c'est la même
problématique que la taxe poids lourds
qu'on a abandonné pour les camions j'ai
fait exactement la même chose sauf que
là ça doit être un accord international
mais y'aura toujours l'accès en france
qui est le premier à première
destination touristique mondiale
eh bien on a quand même des leviers pour
faire en sorte que déjà dans un premier
temps on accueille des avions qui sont
moins polluants par rapport aux autres
qu'on fasse payer une taxe non pas à la
masse de l'avion mais à la tonne
kilomètre transportée ou au passager
kilomètre transporté le moins polluant
par rapport aux autres c'est vrai qu'un
airbus 380 si vous le remplissez à 800
personnes
vous n'êtes pas loin de 2 litres au cent
par passager et donc en mettant ce genre
de facteur sur lequel on a encore la
main
alors on va dire oui mais alors les gens
ils vont se poser à bruxelles et vont se
poser à amsterdam
ils vont plus posé à roissy j'en doute
fort à faire l'effort
de faire une enquête là-dessus mais j'en
doute je pense que on a encore des
leviers pour encore une fois demandé une
contribution un tout petit peu plus
importante
j'ai ça va pas changer grand chose sur
la contribution des des secteurs aérien
et e savez quand vous tapez acheté un
billet d'avion et on vous propose de
compenser votre carbone zéro
d'abord le prix du carbone est tellement
bas que ça change rien et ensuite c'est
pas très incitatif quoi alors il faut
trouver des solutions
voilà vous êtes donc pu suivre
l'audition de gérard feldzer ce
consultant aéronautique et d'auditionner
par la commission d' enquête sur le coût
économique et financier de la pollution
de l'air il a plaidé devant les
sénateurs pour le principe du pollueur
payeur